bon ça va
salut
un papier sur la
toi toi
et l'autre qui plaisait
à
il a faim il
je trouve ça plus tôt
chic
et
je me moque de savoir si j'ai tort ou
un an
je vais tout le
et
oh
m
si je peins 1
agen
pour le croyais
et
je t'aime
une fin
pour la voyez pas
et
m
e
pour car ce prises souvent bas serait
pas rentrer vite
encore plus fort qu'avant
[Musique]
à
mais le score
non
à
et encore
un jour le meilleur sec
aux décideurs
tiens
en soi
à
aho
ça
à
[Applaudissements]
là
et
[Musique]
m
ap
[Musique]
ça fait drôle de voir comme ça calme et
où il était temps enfin julien je vais
pas essayer ça ouais ça me plaît je sais
bien ça vient de 36 ans ouais c'est à
cause de tes origines slaves que tu as
fais attention ouais partie peut-être
non en fait non mais vraiment pas ce que
j'écris j'écris ce truc là sans
connaître du tout l'avis des gens qui y
cherchait un nom pour pour relier les
couplets que j'avais déjà écrit
et puis j'ai dû sa biographie
j'attendais un procès gt gt en tout en
belgique et j'ai vu ce truc là et je
trouve c'était surtout la folie qui va
dans ce maquis
parce qu'en fait c'était pas un mec
dangereux c'est un mec plein d'amour
simple blague run j'ai vachement envie
de ça maintenant d'amour quand tu vas
chez plus envie de le leur ouais plus de
galère plus de
plus de trucs trop brillant parce que
tricher c'est le temps que ça fait 20
ans que tout le monde le sait les
prochaines sa fait 20ans faut passer à
autre chose c'est tout taxi girl ça sera
bientôt 20 ans ouais ouais
ce n'est pas vincent ferniot en taxes et
bien non non non il était alité dans les
civils a réussi leurs produits c'est là
que j'ai vu jouer à la télé je me suis
dit [ __ ] c'est comme une nation
[Musique]
je crois que c'était parce qu'ils sont
venus des mecs de taxes il y aura pas en
exigeant le bail allemand way est un
acquis qui vit au vietnam
laurent saint clair mais ouais c'est un
fait des trucs fût il un studio
il produit ville et rue qui l'a produit
mon album il produit un album de marie
france mais bien les autres je sais pas
ce qu'ils sont il restera l'autre cas
repris ses études
je crois tout
il ya beaucoup de gens avec la mort
quand même je sais pas je suppose quand
tu étais en prison en belgique c'était
pourquoi c'était ok leuthard est très
court c'est aussi bien c'est vachement
mieux ça ça me change beaucoup
ça fait 7 8 mois que je me sens beaucoup
j'avais vachement explorer quand même
face à des nerfs dans cette zone est
tragique et à la fin je trouve cette
dynamique
j'aime passagers aucun sens du comique
je faisais ça n'a pas ce que c'était je
pense que le truc le plus logique
c'était de continuer mais vraiment
terminer vite pour les bâtards d'arrêter
à l'indirect j'ai peur j'ai arrêté
aujourd'hui je sais pas dans 15 jours
mais a fait quelques mois plutôt bien
peuple debout pour ça s'ils font ça que
j'ai arrêté j'avais plus de goût pour sa
santé un problème dans prendre de temps
en temps j'adore je trouve ça génial
mais j'aimerais bien essayer de trouver
l'énergie qu'on peut avoir avec ça au
début une autre façon de la nature et
toi moi ça fait un moment j'ai arrêté ça
fait vraiment ça va faire presque vingt
ans j'ai arrêté je fume des pétards du
bois du champagne sur le subit un ça va
d'ailleurs je me demande comment j'ai pu
faire tout ça des fois c'était bien son
monde restait une époque c'était c'est
vrai c'est vachement plus sordides non
je crois mais c'est peut-être parce qu
extérieurs un truc mais sous les
tropiques c'est toujours été moins
sordide qu'à paris ouais mais un mois
j'avais commencé dans des pays chauds
c'était moins grave
moi j'avais commencé à paris mais
c'était volontaire parce que je voulais
vivre un truc vachement dur banques mais
là ça devient plus dans le dark que new
yorkais quoique mais je trouve très bien
jouer une chanson de temps envie d'y
jouer j'en ai d'écouter de la musique -
cherchez bien sens car si tu veux ouais
bah oui comme soir à leers m
à
cl
c'est m
le
oh
e
son
je venais
alors
un son
ça me semble
la femme se sent quand
oh
e
[Musique]
m
k
son
besson
garçons
une
à
[Musique]
car soupiré
deux cents
e
chez
garçons
[Musique]
sm
g
notre cas
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu